all right joining us now to weigh in on
all today's biggest stories I call him
the great one and he deserves it and he
is about to host a brand-new show right
here on the Fox News Channel because
that's pulling teeth to get him on my
show and it's called life liberty and
Levin thank me
he's also the host of CR TV's Levin TV
the great one I'm so happy you got this
show
I wish too because I've been I beg you
to come on my show but I don't know
about all the waste their time this
pfizer you talk about a pose
constitutional America mark your books
on the Constitution of phenomenal must
read by anybody that cares about it and
we're seeing a presidential candidate
fix a primary who gets an exoneration
before investigation with Comey and
struck I'm talking about Hillary who
then tries to fix by buying you know
bought and paid for Russian propaganda
and then that lot those lies are used to
get a FISA warrant against the
opposition candidate and an incoming
president and his team if that's not
post constitutional I don't know what is
mr. Levin a couple of things about that
is an old chief of staff to an attorney
general at the Justice Department first
of all let me say this as an American
citizen to watch this is repulsive it's
unconscionable to watch the mob media do
what they're doing
last week we were told the president was
mentally unstable for months before that
we're told he's colluding with the
Russians today we're told him we're told
he's a racist
so he's colluding with the Russians he's
mentally unstable he is a racist and
gonna start a nuclear war think it's
it's so outrageous what happened to that
author Michael Wolff three days ago he
was he was the in thing now he's gone
what happened to all the allegations
about the sexual misconduct urban leaves
a confidential meeting with the
president other senators he's relied on
by the media because they want to rely
on him just like they wanted to rely on
that author they want to push this
president out they talked about the 25th
amendment they talked about impeachment
this is the praetorian guard media
the biggest scandal in our lifetime is
staring them in the face you I and a
handful of others seem to care about it
and it is this the politicization of the
highest levels of the FBI and the
Justice Department the holdovers from
the prior administration it's not a
question if Jim Comey the former FBI
director leaked the question is how much
did he leak it's not a question if he
leaked classified information the
question is how much classified
information he was the director of the
FBI the chief investigator who was who
was hunting down Donald Trump sending
texts to his girlfriend hat because he's
cheating on his wife and when I used to
work at the Justice Department you did
that you're out you know why because
they didn't want you to be blackmailed
by of all people the Russians now we
learned there's more texts which appear
to suggest he's been leaking to the
media now we know because there's a
report the Trump administration this is
as of six months ago faced 125 leaked
stories one leaked a day containing
information potentially damaging to our
national security leaks with the
capacity to damage national security
float about seven times as fast as they
did under Bush and the majority of the
leaks during the Trump administration
again this is as of six months ago 78
concerned the Russian probes now talking
about the Russia probe we have a special
counsel who was appointed to do what to
investigate collusion he's investigating
everything but collusion a Special
Counsel does not exist to investigate
financial crimes whether some guy
registered as a federal agent is so
forth he's to investigate collusion
where's your case mr. prosecutor what's
it been six months eight months
give us your collusion case mark now in
addition to him we have this dossier
this is an a' dossier this is 35 pages
of crap that was put together by this
fusion gps they the Hillary Clinton
campaign in the DNC collaborated used
their money to use a law firm to hire
this guy who then hires a British X by
who then works with among others the
creme
that's collusion they put this thing
together and they work it and they give
it to the FBI now the highest levels of
the FBI are very excited to have this
there have been thinking about putting
this expert or spy on their payroll what
do they do with it I know they used it I
know there's a warrant in partner you
know how I know though Sean why won't
the FBI director or why won't anyone at
the Department of Justice when they're
asked say no it wasn't used hey Marc
brought roses holy now put that that
does not reveal classified information
just say no we didn't use it but they
won't say it so they did use it they
absolutely used it we confirmed last
week that they used it I had one reports
is that it was what pushed it over the
top rod Rosenstein when in Oh speaker
Ryan's office according to my reports
and begged him all please don't make us
turn over stuff here's my question its
last question you have a minute to go
we immediate that this is why I want you
on every week never media that all they
put away their word and Bernstein on a
pedestal by the way they did work good
work
interesting work truth and a media that
now is so biased abusively so complicit
even they talk about Watergate mark this
was about influencing a presidential
election using FISA warrants Russian
propaganda Hillary DNC bought and paid
for I think it's much bigger on a scale
that we don't even know yet
and it will be much better you know to
get a FISA warrant you need to have
probable cause that somebody is an agent
or acting as an agent in this case of
Russia committer Muller can anybody at
justice tell us exactly who the Russian
agent was on the trunk campaign there
wasn't any Russian agent I don't know
where the hell does face a judge is but
he or she should be furious and should
be demanding answers to this as for the
media in this country we have a free
press that's fine we also have a stupid
press a very liberal press a a partisan
press I mean when I watch this guy brian
Stelter who i really or this Don Lemon
or over there the
the morning Schmoe and mr. Schmo over
there on MSNBC and silver you call that
press I call that a joke I won't give it
away they're part of our video